[music]
Heat. Heat.
question.
Hey
>> [music]
>> Hello everyone. Welcome, welcome. My
name is Janine Horton. My pronouns are
she and her. We're so glad to see you
all here. Everyone online, thank you for
coming and joining us. I want you to
know that you're not only welcome here,
but you are definitely celebrated here.
Have a couple of announcements for you.
All right. If you are interested in
learning more about baptism and what
that means, then we'll have an
information class uh December the 7th
and the 14th. That'll be before the
services and that'll be for baptisms to
occur on Sunday, January the 11th. So,
if you're interested, RSVP by scanning
the QR code.
All right, Christmas services, everyone.
This is important news. Uh, since our
rental situation doesn't make it, uh,
possible to have a Christmas Eve
service. Uh, then we're having our
annual Christmas service on [snorts]
Sunday, December the 21st. It'll be at
our usual time, 5:00 pm. It will be a
familyfriendly service complete with
carols, candle lighting, mark your
calendars and invite friends and family
to come and be with us during that time.
If you are anxious about being in a
church environment, if you're a part of
the um disability community or just
feeling fidgety today, then we have an
accessibility bucket to my left.
In there you'll find noiseancelling
uh headphones, fidgets, coloring sheets.
We just ask that you return them to the
bucket when you're finished with them at
the end of the service.
All right.
I've lit the candles up front here as a
sign of the presence of Christ among us,
fully divine and fully human.
Let's take a breath.
And now we're going to exit that kingdom
of noise and hurry and productivity.
And we're going to enter into the
kingdom of silence and stillness and
simplicity.
Enter a sacred space,
a place for prayer and worship. and
adoration.
A place to behold Christ,
the revelation of God,
the heartbeat of creation.
Just allow the unforced rhythms of grace
to find you, to envelop you,
to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thank you, Janine. If you guys want to
stand with us, we're gonna open up with
some worship tonight.
So glad that you guys are here and I
just invite you into this space to um
connect with God in [music] a form that
hopefully creates some meaning and um
shifts us out of our
practical day-to-day responsib and
obligations and instead creates this
environment that we get to enter into
together that's creative um hopefully
soulful and mindful and where you can be
introspective for a moment and reflect
on your own inner landscape and [music]
um allow God to be in that space with
you. Um
reminded of that scripture in Proverbs
[music] that says, "Search my heart,
know my anxious thoughts. um see if
[music] there's any offensive way in me
and lead me in your way everlasting. And
I was reading that earlier um this
afternoon and just praying that God
would be with us in [music] this time
and that we would sense his spirit and
his presence um being in [music] this
introspective moment with us where we're
able to say, "Search us, God. Know us.
Be with us." So let's enter into that
together tonight.
spinning out of control.
[music and singing] I feel it losing my
defenses.
No, it's not [music] easy letting
[singing] go and trusting you.
And if I'm being [singing]
honest, I know that though you [singing]
say you've got it, no, it's not [music]
easy letting go [singing] and
you
will
brea rest here in your goodness.
[music and singing]
I know you only it's my confidence.
[singing]
>> I will stop brea rest [music] here in
your goodness. I know [singing] you
only. It's my confidence.
>> I'm sp [music] and out [singing] of
control. I feel it losing my [singing]
defensees.
No, it's not [music]
easy letting go [singing]
and trusting you.
[singing]
I know that though you've said you've
got it, no it's not easy letting [music]
[singing] go and trusting you.
So [music] we'll stop. I will stop
brea rest here in your goodness. [music]
I know you won't [singing] leave. It's
my confidence.
[music]
>> I will stop.
Breathe. Rest [singing] here in your
goodness. I know [music] you only. It's
my confidence.
>> It's my confidence.
>> Here [singing] I am in [music] the palm
of your hand. Nothing can take me away.
Nothing can take me [singing] away. Here
I am in the palm of your hand. Nothing
can take me away. Nothing
[music and singing] can take me away.
[music]
Not a [music]
death or a lie inside my head. Not a
fear or a fence. Nothing [music] can
take me away. Let's sing that again. Not
a nor.
[music and singing]
[music]
[singing]
Not a fear or a fence. Nothing [music]
can take me away.
Not a hide or [singing] a death. Not a
[music] lie inside my head. Not a fear
[singing] or a fence. Nothing can take
me away. [music]
Here [singing] I am in the palm of your
hand. Nothing can take me away. Nothing
can take me away. [music]
Here I am in the palm
[music and singing] of your hand.
Nothing can take me away. Nothing can
take me away. It's my [music]
confidence.
>> It's my confidence.
>> It's my confidence. [singing]
>> It's my confidence. [music and singing]
>> It's my confidence.
[music]
All right, I think we have a few kiddos
who can head out to kids ministry
tonight. Your teachers are going to meet
you over by the double doors.
All right. And as they make their way
out, we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people. So you can follow
along on the screens [music] and read
the sections in red aloud together.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth that you have [music] given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it. We pray to you for the old
and the sick, for the widow and orphan,
for the injured and suffering. We pray
to you for the poor and the oppressed,
the unemployed and destitute, for
prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them. We pray to
you for the vulnerable, the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender, sexuality, race, or other
perceived difference. We pray to you for
those experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you. Lord, we know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence. Amen.
[singing]
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, [music and singing] we want your
living
flowing [singing]
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, [singing]
we want [music]
your living
water [singing]
flowing [music]
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, [music and singing]
we want your living
water [singing and music]
from the heart of the [singing] father.
Jesus, we [music] want your living water
[singing]
flowing [music]
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, sing that one last time.
[music]
[singing]
Father,
Jesus, we want you.
Who are you?
I've cared [music]
a burden
[music] for too long on my own.
I wasn't created
to bear it on.
I hear [singing] your invitation
to let [music and singing] it all go.
But I see it now. I'm laying [music] it
down.
And [singing] I know that I [music] need
you. [singing] I run to the father.
[music]
I fall into grace. I'm done
[music and singing] with the hiding.
The reason
my [music] heart needs a searching. My
soul needs [singing] a friend. So
[music] I run to the father [singing]
again and again and again and again.
Oh,
[singing]
[music] you saw my condition.
[music]
Had a plan from my start.
>> [music]
>> Your son for redemption
the [singing and music] price for my
heart.
>> I don't have a [singing]
[music]
>> for that kind of love. [singing]
I [music] don't understand.
I can't comprehend. [singing]
All I know is [music] I
need to you [singing]
run to the father. I [music] fall into
grace. I'm done [singing] with the
hiding. I reason [music] to wait. And my
heart needs a searching. My soul
[music and singing] needs a friend. So I
run to the father again
[music and singing] and again and again
and again.
Oh [singing]
[music]
[singing]
again and again.
Oh, [music and singing]
[singing]
[music] my heart is been in your sight
long before my
first breath.
running into [music]
your
arms is running to life
from [singing]
death.
I [music] feel this rush
deep in my [singing] chest. Your mercy
is calling [music]
out
just [singing] as I am. You pull me
[music] in. And I know [singing] I need
you [music] now. I run to the father. I
fall [music] into grace. I'm done
[singing] with the hearting. No reason
[music] to wait. My heart needs a sur.
My soul [music and singing] needs a
friend. So I run to the father again
[music] and again.
I run to [singing] the father. I fall
into grace. I'm done [music and singing]
with the hiding. The reason
my [music and singing] heart found a
searching. My soul found a friend. So I
run [music and singing] to the father
again and again and again and again.
Oh
[singing and music]
again again.
Oh. [music]
Oh. [singing]
Again.
>> Water flowing from [music] the heart
[singing] of the father.
Jesus. [music] We want your living
water. Flowing [singing and music]
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, [singing and music]
we want your living
water flowing [singing and music]
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, [singing] we were your living
flow
from [singing] the heart of the father.
Jesus, [music and singing] we want you.
We want [music]
you
Jesus. [music]
[singing]
We need your love.
God, we open our hearts tonight and make
room for you.
and your spirit and what [music] you
want to do inside of us. What you want
to speak to us as our creator, our
maker.
As Jesse continues to play, can you guys
just take a moment to think about what
it might be that you're needing
from God?
If you can just name that with him
tonight.
Maybe it's strength
or hope.
Maybe it's forgiveness.
Maybe it's restoration.
Peace.
Spirit of God, we make room for you to
come and do your good work in our
hearts.
God, would we have soil that is ready to
be planted in?
ready to receive from you.
Would you find good ground where things
can grow and thrive?
Your goodness, your peace, your
forgiveness,
your strength.
ready our hearts for you,
God. We want more of you.
Help us to make room for it.
Help us to hear your voice, to listen
for your voice.
It's in Jesus name we pray. Amen.
Right. Can you Turn to the person beside
you and say, "The peace of Christ be
with you." And then you may be seated.
Well, grace and peace. It is good to be
with you all. My name is Brett and uh
pronouns he him and it's a joy joy to be
with you to welcome you into this space
and as always that includes those join
us online. Y'all are not forgotten.
Thanks for being with us and don't
forget to get your communion elements
for later in the service. We always love
when you can join in with us uh in that.
And uh yeah, and also just a warm
welcome to all of you if this your first
time or just your first time in a while.
We're really glad that you're that
you're here. So, um, let's see. The
title of my message this week is the
process of suffering. Woohoo. You're
like, "Yeah, getting all right."
[laughter]
I am uh I'm I am I'm hopeful to bring
some life to it, though. You know, I
think suffering is sort of one of those
things we can spend our lives avoiding
or we can just kind of name it and uh
[laughter] learn how to to work through
it, you know, better. So, uh, hopefully
it won't be, you know, kind of like a
kind of a message, but, um, next week I
want to name we're, um, going into
Advent and so this kind of time of like
heart and mind preparation, uh, leading
up to the season of Christmas. So, um,
that'll be a really special, uh, kind of
few weeks as we lead into the the
Christmas service that Johnny was
talking about. And yeah, so I encourage
you if you can be here, um, you won't
want to miss that, uh, that time. So,
let's see. Our our gospel reading is uh
from Luke 23 verse is 33 and 34 and uh
it says this. When they came to the
place called the skull, they crucified
him there along with the criminals, one
on his right, the other on his left.
Jesus said, "Father, forgive them for
they do not know what they are doing."
So the, you know, the the cross of
Jesus, it's an incredibly it's a it's a
powerful symbol. And I think if you
could say this even about a, you know, a
kind of image and a a picture of like
torture. I think it even has a certain
beauty um about it. And uh so my message
today, I'm not going to try to like sum
up, you know, all the theology of the
cross and all that it means. uh instead
I just want to give you kind of one
maybe approach, one angle um that kind
of sees the cross as this teaching and
really Jesus approach to the cross more
than just the moment of crucifixion but
even this kind of lead lead into it um
as this kind of uh process of uh of
suffering and a kind of approach to it a
teaching about it. Um now before we jump
in I want to give you like kind of a
quick footnote on this. So basically
theology uh about the cross and
sacrifice and suffering. Um I'd say it's
a lot of nuance is needed on this. Um
there's been some kind of like really
from starting like maybe the 80s and 80s
90s there was like uh feminist uh
theology and um what's called womanist
theology which is sort of like um a
black feminism kind of thinking about
the cross and seeing uh the ways we've
kind of preached it and taught it and
kind of the emphasis on you know
sacrifice sacrifice suffering and
suffering. It can be good. It can be
good. That it it kind of almost uh not
almost but it led to this a kind of uh
too extreme view of it where it was like
it was just only good and they started
to kind of poke holes in that in helpful
ways. Um pointing out for example that
uh women right and you can see where a
feminist is coming from that
perspective. Women, especially in the
church, were often taught to um be kind
of in that uh sacrificial
uh suffering role, often even at times
in like abusive marriages and the
perspective of like church leadership
and such was
was kind of seeing them almost through
the lens of Christ and then would say
like, "Oh, well, you know, this is
you're just um you're just suffering for
Christ. you're entering into Christ's
sufferings
and so can't you you know kind of this
it got really bad toxic you know where
it was kind of encouraging people
basically to end up staying in um not
good relationships abusive relationships
so right so feminists kind of critiqued
that and it was good it was like a
necessary critique um over time that
kind of that conversation's continued
and some feminists now are kind of
working to maybe recover some of these
notions Because from their perspective,
maybe that pendulum got swung a little
too far, you know, to where it was like
not sacrifice good, sacrifice bad, you
know, just bad suffering, bad. No, just
don't don't even think about don't even
try to preach on that or talk about it
or ah because that's just leads us to
abusive paths, you know. And they said,
well, um, for example, they pointed out
that um, motherhood itself
is sacrifice, [laughter]
you know, is there some suffering in in
even motherhood? and they said, "Well,
you know, what doesn't feminism need
room for for motherhood?" You know, so
that's kind of that's sort of a whole
conversation that's kind of going on.
And I name it because, you know, just
anytime I'm teaching here on sacrifice,
suffering, and such, I I think we we
need a lot of nuance. It just can't be
as simple as sacrifice, good, sacrifice,
bad, suffering, good, suffering bad.
This is like this is too clunky, you
know? What what kind of sacrifice do you
have in mind? what what kind of
suffering what's the context you know uh
to what degree is this kind of willed
and chosen to what degree is this forced
upon someone you know what I mean so at
any rate I just want to kind of name
that footnote right here at the
beginning uh for those who might be
having some of those questions you know
rumbling around the back of their their
mind as we as we kind of get into this.
So uh this idea of kind of the the life
of Christ and his journey to the cross
as this kind of teaching on suffering. I
I came across this from a pastor um
named Peter Hos and uh his church of
conscious harmony a contemplative
Christian community in Austin, Texas.
And what he kind of named I'd always
seen the cross this way. What I hadn't
tuned into was the way the kind of days
really um months and years leading up to
the cross was this kind of journey into
suffering. That's what Peter Hos pointed
out that I was kind of like, huh, I'd
never I'd never thought of it like that.
I think I kind of had this separation a
little bit from like Jesus life and then
like the cross and I didn't see this
kind of continual kind of journey into
suffering. And so that kind of got me
thinking and so I want to what I want to
unpack in this message is kind of the
maybe some phases of suffering that
might help you even kind of map a little
bit on kind of where you are in your own
you know journey and then give you some
handles for um how you can kind of live
in to that. Um so phase one of suffering
we'll call this imagining
imagining suffering. uh Matthew 16:21,
this takes place maybe 6 to 12 months uh
before the crucifixion. It says this,
"From that time on, Jesus began to
explain to his disciples that he must go
to Jerusalem and suffer many things at
the hands of the elders, the chief
priests, and the teachers of the law,
and that he must be killed on the third
day uh or and on the third day be raised
to life." And uh if you've read the
gospels, you know these moments where
Jesus kind of predicts this suffering
that will come. In fact, just a a few
verses after this passage I just read,
Peter takes him aside and like criti
criticizes him. He's like, "You can't
talk like this." But Jesus like doubles
down. He insists like, "No, no, this is
how it's going to be." And I think here
you have kind of imagined suffering,
right? Like this is at this point for
Christ, it's all future
suffering. You know, he's not it's not
something he's undergoing now. It's just
predicting like this is this is coming.
And uh I think we can kind of relate to
this in that we've all know the
difference between like imagined
suffering and actual suffering. And
these are two very different things.
Even though in the moment of the
imagined suffering, I think we often
think we know, you know what I mean?
Until we get into it and then we're
like, "Oh god, this is not what I
bargain for." You know what I mean? Like
this. No, no, no, no, no, no. I think um
maybe a little bit of a silly example um
considering our subject matter, but um
one example this in our lives might be
have you ever had this moment where you
told someone or a group of someone's
like about the like training plan,
workout program, couch to 5K you were
going to do.
You ever had this conversation with
someone like we're kind of in that time
now where it's November and like January
is coming and sometimes people make
those resolutions or you know what I
mean? It's kind of like I'll just tell
you there's nothing easier than sitting
on the couch talking to someone about
the couch to 5k program that you're
going to do. You know, I mean the 5k I'm
going to run the let me tell you about
the marathon I'm going to run. You know
it's oh it's going to be great. know um
this is just a very different uh
experience
and it it often I think we actually get
into suffering right it just kind of
kicks us in the face right there's just
a world of difference between the idea
of suffering and actually uh really
truly
uh entering into that and suffering so
this kind of leads to phase two uh which
is objecting
right this is when like we're actually
into
the experience and uh we've we've kind
of left theory now we've entered reality
we're starting to live it and as I
mentioned like it's way harder than we
think and the mind goes wild I mean at
least I don't know about yours mine goes
wild like every fiber of my being is
like resisting
um complaining fighting disliking
And kind of weirdly, it can even come on
the heels of something we thought we
wanted, like you know, we get that
promotion or whatever, but now the
responsibility is like completely
stressing us out and the mind's just
going, you know, crazy. Or uh a common
experience for folks here at the table,
you know, someone uh comes out
and it's kind of beautiful and
liberating. Um, and at the same time
there's like this backlash
where
friends start abandoning and grandma is
judging and the holidays are looming and
our mind just starts going wild with
like actual reality and the suffering
that we're undergoing,
right? or the the children that you
hoped and prayed for, they are wonderful
and meaningful, but also a total handful
and you're screaming at like a
2-year-old at 900 p.m., you know, like I
shared before, this is like always my
worst time as a parent is always like
bedtime. Um, my kids were little. I
don't know how kids I thought kids would
get so sleepy after dinner, you know,
just kind of like, "Oh, I'm so tired.
Just ate. Belly's full, you know." No,
it is like peak bath time is peak
energy. They're just like like going
nuts. And I remember going into it and I
would tell myself like because of course
it was a routine every night like eight
years, you know, we're like bathing and
I couldn't get used to it. I was kind of
like, "All right." I would tell myself
little pep talks like Brett, chill
Brett. It's tonight is going to be
contemplative Brett. Like just I'm gonna
this is I'm going to play this one cool
no matter what they do. And sure enough,
like some freaking towel would end up in
the bath like in it. And I was just
like, "Oh my gosh, I'm gathering." I
would just at some point I would just
lose it. I'M JUST LIKE, [screaming] YOU
KNOW, oh my, it was a disaster. Even
last night, I thought this would get
better. Now, of course, the kids, you
know, I don't have to bathe them. Thank
God. But now it's we're into the season
of um friends spending the night. So
like last night, I literally find myself
10 p.m. I'm exhausted,
so tired.
And it wasn't even that bad. They were
just being loud. You know what I mean?
And I'm literally like I won't say the
kid's name. JUST LIKE CHILD. I'M LIKE,
"YEAH, child's name."
[screaming]
You know? Oh my gosh.
See, that's the moment like that's when
you can have all your plan. I love uh
what Mike Tyson had that saying about I
think he actually took it from another
boxer, but everyone has a plan until
they get punched in the face, you know?
And that's kind of suffering, you know.
Everyone has a plan. Everyone talks a
big game and they get punched in the
face by the reality of the suffering.
It's like, "Oh Lord, I no, I can't do
this. I can't do that." You know, this
is the objecting phase. I think I've
even um had kind of a similar
experience. It's maybe not quite that
dramatic, but a little bit as a a church
planter and and just being kind of in
church world like um you know, I'll say
there's nothing like sort of more pure
than like the idea of a church, you
know. And then there's like the actual
lived reality of a church. And um and by
the way, I'm not just putting that on
you all. You all are so disappointed. I
mean, like me too. You know what I mean?
Like it's sort of all of us together
like yep, we are human beings. And uh in
fact some of you will have if you
haven't already like maybe you're still
in the honeymoon phase with the table
like this is I found the perfect church.
I can't believe it. Well uh you will
have this moment when it kind of reality
sets in. It's like oh they're just just
people you know and maybe even hurts
feelings and suffering you know it's
like this is like community. This is why
often people love the idea of community.
They just don't want the suffering that
like actual community and friendship and
relationship like really in real life
actually requires.
Uh and then the mind just goes wild, you
know, wild crazy objecting, arguing,
complaining, moaning, resisting.
And uh some of you some of you you're
there now, you know, the actual
suffering. You're like, "This marriage
is not what I bargained for. This
political climate is freaking eating me
alive. I I am one missed paycheck away
from financial disaster.
Maybe it's even just kind of identity
stuff, you know, does anyone even see
me? Does anyone even notice me? Does
anyone love me or care even care that
I'm here? Like these thoughts just like
journey journey journey, right? You're
just in the midst of this this pain, you
know, phase two. It's hard. Actual
suffering is hard. What's interesting
and I think helpful though is that Jesus
had these moments too. You might recall
um that night before the crucifixion
uh in the garden of Gethsemane. Luke 22
beginning in verse 39 says, "Jesus went
out as usual to the Mount of Olives and
his disciples uh followed him. On
reaching the place, he said to them,
"Pray that you will not fall into
temptation. He withdrew about a stones
throw beyond them, knelt down, and
prayed, "Father, if you're willing,
take this cup from me."
It's interesting that that even Jesus
had this moment. It's like not so sure
about this cross.
Makes me feel a little bit better about
all those times when I like talked a big
game, [laughter] you know. And then when
the actual suffering hit, all I wanted
was out. I just wanted out. No matter
what, I just want out. You know that
moment when I don't feel up for the
journey.
Yeah, you've been there. You're not
alone.
You're not alone, friend. We've all been
there. This is the human condition, but
it's not the end of the story. Phase
three, accepting.
accepting. I I do think um
well, you can see where back to my
little footnote at the beginning, you
can see where this becomes a little
tricky, you know, which is why I say
this needs nuance, but there is
something about accepting the reality of
suffering. Again, not talking about
staying in an abusive relationship or
something, but just in like life
presents us with these things. And hey,
if you can change it, if you can change
your circumstances in a way, great. go
for it. You know what I mean? Like, but
sometimes you're just in that mode,
that's when suffering is really hard,
where it's like, "No, there's not an
easy out here." And this is the moment
where actually
instead of resisting it, right, which is
the objecting phase, moaning,
complaining, disliking, like, "No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no."
Instead, getting out of that mode and
saying yes,
yes. Like this this kind of willed um
acceptance. It's incredibly powerful.
And I I think um maybe a metaphor here
might be it's a little bit like being in
the objecting phase. It's kind of like
going through life trying to drive with
your foot on both the gas and the
brakes.
Can you imagine? It's like not a good
way to drive, you know? But it's there's
this both move forward. Yes. And a
break. A no no. Yes. No. No. Yes. Yes.
No. You know what I mean?
And you can see where when we finally
let our foot off the brake, then I think
what we're afraid of is like, well, then
my suffering will triple. If I say yes
to this, I I just accept that this
actually is how my life is currently and
there's a certain sense in which I need
to accept it. Well, it's going to get
worse. Uh this is kind of the paradox.
What what do we what do we find? um that
actually the resisting
itself, the breaking itself was so much
of the suffering itself, right? In
essence, kind of back to um last week if
you were here, we talked about the egoic
false self, right? And that's this
raring its ugly head again where it's
it's this this ego mind with its
ruminating and storytelling and
complaining and disliking and no, no,
no, it shouldn't be. It shouldn't be. It
shouldn't be when it is, you know. Um
that is so much of um the problem itself
after um our last worship night about
was that a month month or so ago um
Maggie and I were having a discussion
about worship and and uh just kind of
what's going on there and we were
talking about like the various postures
of worship you know the kind of open
hands or open arms um and this kind of
how it's this it's this picture of um
like not forcing something but it's kind
of a picture of like receiving you know
when I think of the posture of worship.
It's not, you know, it's not this, you
know, but instead it's this kind of it's
this openness. And uh Maggie had just
been thinking on it for like a day or
two and she said, I
is
is worship itself is it like is it just
a picture of like the spiritual life as
a whole?
And is it really all just surrender?
And I said, I I think so. Like I think
like 99% of it is
surrender is like God slowly but surely
bringing us to this place where we're
like,
"Okay." Yes.
Yes. something a little practice I've
been working on is actually um receiving
my day in my life just as it is without
needing to like jazz it up, change it
up, distract myself to you know
something like and it's been so much
harder than I thought it would be. But
in a way it's like it's not some big
dramatic suffering. It's like a small
suffering like just to, you know, go on
a walk and not listen to a podcast, you
know what I mean? Which sounds
ridiculous, but it's like weirdly hard,
you know what I mean? Or to get in the
car and not distraction, distraction,
quickly, quickly, turn on the radio, you
know what I mean? But just to kind of be
or or um
yeah to to go and um just be present to
someone, you know, it's there's a
there's a kind of willed acceptance of
our life which is um surprisingly
difficult. But as we can say yes to it,
it's like there's uh I don't know
there's life begins to teach us. God
begins to teach us through like our
actual life. But again, it's sort of
like we have to take our foot off the
brake though to to start to get the
lesson to to learn. Um, I see this it's
almost a kind of softening that can
happen, you know, becoming gentle
um to life, to ourselves, to others. Um,
I heard uh well, one one way you can see
this is in like like older folks, you
know, they tend to um
kind of go into one of two extremes.
It's almost like if you live your whole
life in that kind of phase two objecting
mode, then that plays out,
you know, and you end up kind of
becoming this kind of embittered,
complaining,
incredibly intensely negative person.
You know what I mean? It's almost like
you can hide it in your 20s or
something, but let that play out for 80
years and you become a person. You know
what I mean? And vice versa, someone
who's able to kind of relax. You met
older folks who are just like very
relaxed. You know, there is a certain
surrender. There's an acceptance of even
themselves in their own failings and
shortcomings that allows them then to be
gentle with others. Uh I think this is
a profound a profound thing to start to
understand and begin to embrace. We see
this phase in that same passage from
Luke 22:42
where so Jesus was there in the garden,
right? He says, "Father, if you're
willing, take this cup from me." And yet
what? And yet not my will, but yours be
done.
Can you hear the acceptance in that? In
fact, those were some of the final
words, some of the last words of Christ
on this earth, right? Not my will, but
yours be done. There's a kind of
softening there and openness and
acceptance that leads to phase four and
I'll close with this coming back to our
opening passage or I should say this
phase four is forgiving forgiving uh
Luke 23:33 again when they came to the
place called the skull they crucified
him there along with the criminals one
on his right the other on his left Jesus
said father forgive them for they do not
know what they are doing
what I want to point out is the
connection there
between the the three previous phases
and that one. I think for many of us,
forgiveness is a bit of a mystery, you
know, like how on earth am I supposed to
forgive that person? You know, like we
often have a story or an experience like
not just the little petty stuff. It's
like, yes, I can forgive that, you know,
but like the big things we're like
there's no way how am I supposed to get
to a place of forgiveness? And I think
in this sense,
uh, forgiveness, it's not something
that's really forced.
It it really is a a place, a state we
find ourselves in
after
we ourselves have suffered some and
after we've gone through some of these
previous phases. Does that make sense?
So, um, it's not as easy as like a
to-do, you know what I mean? Like do the
laundry and then forgive, you know, like
it's it's not going to be like that.
that it's this it's this it's this
journey and it's something really we um
I think in so many ways we receive. Um
I also love this this line about Jesus
saying they don't know what they are
doing.
That's in that's incredibly insightful
because isn't our story they know
exactly what they're doing. You know
what I mean? They know exactly what. But
yeah, as you journey though and start to
see your own messed upness, you realize
like those moments when you are being
like your worst, so to speak, you are
often being bullied and pushed around by
your own past and conditioning and
suffering.
Does that make sense? So then you can
start to have mercy on others when you
realize like, oh, they're like the same
as me. You know what I mean? Like it's
almost like all of my shortcomings are
like kind of mistakes and an accident,
you know, or a kind of irrational like
my mind was just taken over, you know,
was being stupid, you know, but everyone
else's is like very cold and calculated,
you know what I mean? Um, when I think
the truth is we're we're all being um
kind of pushed around by these things.
Um, I really do think it's true. Humans
don't know what we're doing. Um,
however, if by God's grace and our own
commitment to this path, if we're able
to kind of move through these phases, I
think we'll enter this fourth phase
where we truly can learn to forgive
everyone
for everything.
I think that's like kind of the pinnacle
of the spiritual life in a lot of ways.
Like when we get to that place where we
really are just naturally forgiving
everyone for everything.
That's that's a place of profound
freedom.
And it's a a place that I pray each of
us even no matter where we are on the
journey, you know, that each of us could
be pointed towards living into.
Yeah. A freedom I pray finds each and
every one of you. In the name of the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held a loaf of
bread and he broke it. He said, "Take it
and eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." Then he held up a cup of wine.
He said, "Take this drink. This is my
blood. it shed for you. Whenever you eat
this bread, whenever you drink this cup,
remember me.
So as you come forward, you can bring
yourself and your story and your
suffering and pain, whatever you you're
carrying in this place. Bring it bring
it here. Lay it at the the feet of
Christ, the one who suffers with and
alongside you. So the way we'll go about
this is we'll just go rowby row,
starting here at the front, forming one
line in the middle. Um, we practice
what's called an open table. And if
you're here tonight and you want to
participate, then you're free to do that
regardless of your, you know,
denomination or theological beliefs or
whatever. If you want to connect with
Jesus, then you you come forward to
receive. The red is wine, the white is
grape juice. And finally, you can just
partake whenever and however you'd like.
Some folks like to take right away, some
like to come and kneel. Um, but no one
will lead you through the exact moment
of taking. So this is the table, not of
the church, but of the Lord.
And it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more. So come you who have much faith
and you who have little. You who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long. You who have tried to
follow and you who feel like you failed.
Come. Come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you. And it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come to the table.
If you guys want to stand with us for
this last song, we're going to close um
with a song called The Breastplate of
St. Patrick. And I love that this song
names just a lot of little very
relatable moments of suffering that so
many of us have experienced if not all
of us. Um but then just invites Christ
into that moment with us. So we'll close
out with that tonight.
When my work takes me places,
Christ be
my [music] heartaches with sorrow as I
hit the road.
Christ be with me
when the care of my [singing] family
[music] takes all that I have.
Christ within
me when I'm [singing] worn and exhausted
ashamed that I'm mad.
Christ [music]
defend
me.
>> I rise up today [singing]
in a strength [music] that is not my
own.
>> I'm held [singing] by the promise of
[music] God that I'm never alone.
When I'm tossed to the side and I want
to give up,
Christ bead
[music]
me when I'm breaking my back, but it's
never [music] enough.
Christ beside [music]
me
>> when I [singing] work hard but [music]
else gets the reward.
>> God's [singing]
eyes [music] see
when I ask for promotion
and they shut the door.
God's ears hear me.
>> I rise [singing] up today in [music] the
strength that is not my own.
>> I'm held by the promise of God [singing]
that [music] I'm never alone.
When I [singing] climb the first steps
toward a longheld
dream,
Christ above [music]
me, I leap out in faith [singing] and I
hope to [music] find
Christ be
Christ
me.
Sorry about that. So, in the moment, it
was beautiful. Okay. Thank you all for
being here tonight. Uh if you are a
visitor, we would really like for you
[music] to fill out a card or go online
at the QR code and fill out a visitor's
card so we can just check with you. Um
if you want to have a a more relational
support or spiritual connection, I think
we can all use that [music] in our
lives. The way we do that here at the
table is we do it through our Meetup
groups. So again, the QR code is the key
to all things table.
All right. Uh, generosity is a key
aspect of a life of [music] adoration
and worship. And if the table is your
church home, then we [music] invite you
to scan that magical QR code and uh to
give financially or you can go [music]
online at thetabletx.org.
All right, it's time now for me to send
you out with a [music] benediction.
If you would like to just uh raise your
hands in a posture of receiving or open
your heart uh to these words,
you are a child of God.
Yes, you are a child of God.
And this is true on your very best day
and it's true on your worst day.
So, as you go into your week ahead with
all of its yet to be determined highs
and lows and everything in between,
go and know that you are assured that
you are loved, that you are [music]
worthy,
and that you are accepted just as you
are.
go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
that you come in contact with.
Be blessed and we will see you next
Sunday. Amen.
I'll rise up today in [music] the
strength [singing] that is not my own.
>> I'm held [singing and music] by the
promise of God that I'm never alone.
When I climb [singing] the first [music]
steps toward a longheld
dream,
Christ [music]
leap out [music and singing] in faith
and I hope to find
Christ be [music]
Christ
missed opportunity.